ces beautés se laver le visage chef à
l'autre et fret way nos très frais ça
réveille le matin à quoi ça sert de
socle à voter oui c'est mon secret
beauté d'accord il ya un truc à dire
la pac petite crème un petit quelque
chose ah non mais après bien sûr mais
d'abord vraiment de l'eau fraîche sur le
visage ah ouais ouais votre secret
beauté ces nouvelles soit masque filorga
filorga merci à
l'auteur
ni vers
un cd m2 herman's hermits visage tous
les quinze jours ah ouais ouais ouais
objections d'accord alors jetez pas posé
la caisse
là c'est pas des injections
donné la piqûre d'avoir la taille de
vernet
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme quand vous gonfler le bleu
le porter comme atik de bojan cette idée
plusieurs j'en peux plus j'ai fait que
la pommette vas-y fais tout
sans déconner normal mais j'adore et les
injections vous très bien je fais pas
d'injection ce soir ribéry
le visage on dirait qu'il a mis du bail
n'est sur la gueule c'était bon
à
lugano n'a pas fait d'injections les
rliss à rien c'est une marque à lui le
on saura en saura plus tard mais sans
déconner l'huile alors lui si lui l'a
pas fait l'injection mais sans déconner
vous avez vos joues qui sont en train de
rentrer dans votre touche
beaucoup moins six semaines
alors c'est sûr tu as tu lu la dictée
fait des années que j'ai fait un peu de
botox a alors c'est quoi alors le botox
et botox et la ballade de la red bull et
ferrari est un peu c'est gonflé
l'attendre un sac de béziers avec un peu
la tête en direct mais évidemment c'est
qu'on ne fait pas
bander connaissent et adorent ça te va
très bien et ne mens pas je vous renvoie
les bars ne ment jamais l'émission toi
d'abord de droit
[Musique]
tu manges tu as ta bouche je te rappelle
qu'il faut manger cinq fruits secteur
par jour
est ce que vous trouvez normal qu'ils
démarrent l'émission en mangeant nord
doit sinon il n'est pas bien il en
hypoglycémie et déjà pas le faire cinq
minutes avant l'entamé ya toujours pas
compris je suis animateur
ce portail avait une réunion de
chroniqueurs je n'étais pas là ça vous à
la renaissance d un peu les boules
hausse
[Applaudissements]
dimanche à l'antenne mille excuses moi
est-ce que tu l'as déjà vu manger à
l'antenne suspect on a chacun nos petits
trucs son petit truc là toi ça va être
assez chez
[Rires]
lui il va scanner n'ont pas ramassé
alors vote secret beauté mais reçoit
l'as fait ça tous les soirs à tous les
soirs toulotte secrets beauté parce que
leur vote
pour le coup c'est réussi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bordas qui marque
déjà le régime buts à rien et légumes
c'est un
coup de tisanes de petites sommes ouais
de tisanes d un physique les petites
âmes c'est comme des petits dons s'est
déportée dans les pizzas oui j'utilise
beaucoup d'huile en fait je fais des
masques à l'huile sur le visage et des
masques à l'huile sur le cheveu est moi
qui conduis là
ce soir je vais manger chez ma mère je
sais que tu es moche et je serais lui je
la mets sur la baie oui avant quand tu
fais là prêt il est ce soir j'ai pas la
peine
alors et donc ouais et donc ça va ouais
c'est ça et après deux footings par
semaine et puis ça ouais de footing ce
nom ouais bah ouais c'est pas mal quand
même un corps indépendant la bravoure
mais c'est plus bas mais attention à eux
je le dis et quand on entend parfois
nous sommes tous égaux
aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe certains sont
plus égaux que d'autres
lundi c'est à peu près ce que je fais ça
doit être de fabrique pas sûr et nous
fait beaucoup de piscines c2c le secret
nommé double secret
et puis ça me fait pas débité
[Applaudissements]
ll fabien barcella sur la tête de ma
mère je connais des gens comme ça même
bébé frères ils font déjà un mètre 80
quand il sort il est comme h et la
raiffeisen
ou bien les gens tombent ami
médecin
sur ma vie j'ai bien géré ma vie elle
une idée à la mer du jour
combien d'enfants
il croyait il avait 3 soit dan demers on
rigolait elle s'est quand même un train
il ya plein de bagdad nous les
qualifions nous quand on s'offre un
médecin
[Applaudissements]
comme sorte comme à paris c'est pourquoi
on a des ongles ou des poids de hyères
jeu propre à nos frères sont ma vie elle
devait selon jean une frite une
végétalisation raté nouvelle banking sur
ma ville seront ainsi la sortie sur ma
vie c'est ma ligne tu sors un enfant
quand même déjà mesure 1 m 75 à la
naissance pour atteindre ma mère elle
est comme un essor le bébé défilent
comme
le bt et le bbd ton karman dans la
maternité le bébé à la dévotion
dans la matinée
nous en sommes nous encore les tunisiens
soit est dans la merde et jarnac dark
knight sur mamy surnommèrent de l'aréna
fixe à la somavie on est fort sera la
totale et là on commence mon métier et
la joie
c'est le bébé de la 403
ses deux bébés spieser
bébé tellement moche que n'avait pas
brad et moi de me montrer non c'est pas
parce que j'étais plein d'eczéma et au
regard des croûtes partout où j'étais un
vrai come away et ça aussi bon je vais
vous chanter dans le livre
[Applaudissements]
a tout oublié de lire ce livre j'ai
commencé et un bébé à boire du lait
végétal de donner ta mère données du gps
est attendu d'un moment à fond mais doit
la sortie
d'amendé tout ça et c'est à partir de ce
moment là
sur la tête de ma mère mais sur mer
avait écrit alors et c'est beau et que
le végétal ça m'a donné beaucoup
d'espoir est devenu très belle à quel
âge
je pense à partir de 3 ans ouais
[Rires]
venez je suis
c'est quand j'ai arrêté de manger de la
viande mais c'est à nous raconter votre
vie je l'accueille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît noter la beauté pour
vous voyez bien sévère
et magnifique merci alors le premier
secret chevalet au chauffeur de salle
vous essayé le botox médicale coisy les
deux parties du visage qui se séparent
ah oui et doit y aller le cerveau 6 1
et donc je suis obligé d'avoir trois
injections de chaque côté avant que les
deux infinis si vous regardez bien ces
dix ans notre jeu voilà donc ça c'est le
premier secret malgré l'injection je
suis obligé parce que les deux parties
vont séparer sinon que ne s'agit qu'un
temps
et le deuxième secret et là je voudrais
que vous soyez gentils c'est que fatou
s'occupe de moi
ouais et donc notament non
s'il vous plaît ne dit on
environ 120 kg 1
pour fatou vos artères pour fatou lui va
pas j'ai beaucoup à tout ce qu'on sait
pas qui est responsable de ce massacre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cinquante ans des méchants
du tout dedans fin tout il est tout
content brainard mais c'est un bravo
parce que vous êtes magnifique merci non
mais c'est vrai c'est grâce à elle
peut-être de plus en plus bel homme
qu'est ce que ce serait comme soins par
exemple alors elle mais pire gueule
il allait faire le lyncher
les
battre à
4 ans et
10 mois gilles
débarrasser tout ça c'est pour tes soins
beauté que ce n'est
pas vous épie des prêts et des piles ou
sourcils et les mots sourcils votre
magnifique ça c'est brad où je cherchais
un truc
je suis assez un truc qui ressortait pas
vu le film oui oui la ligne oui là et al
ahly mais elle me met beaucoup de crème
ah oui
et ben bravo à dire si ces jeux secrets
beauté jeu au filet
daniel et mathieu bout ah bah oui c'est
pas secret beauté sans rigoler lui l'
univers la rive avec une vanne
de fond là des crèmes de tout pas j'en
ai pas pensé pour être sacré j'ai un
lait végétal way aux extraits d'un monde
j'ai une crème à la banane j'ai un rôle
donne pour les cernes que j'applique
plein midi et soir on est renvoi par
semaine j'ai une lotion revitalisante
pour les joues que j'applique uniquement
le matin et je fais un massage facial
aussi le soir
vous avez le temps de travail et que
tout
ça va arriver mais en tout cas c'est
réussi à une jolie peau il a une
poubelle sans rigoler j'ai envie de
faire sur la tête de ma mère l'avait un
peu j'ai vu surya bonaly sur sa peau
tellement envie de
vous sachiez c'est que lui en plus il a
un budget crème extraordinaire faut
savoir un topo son front seulement ces
trois crèmes 3 3 tués par jour non mais
sans rire il a une surface non mais
c'est vrai on mentionne alors c'est
incroyable mais franchement tu as
d'ailleurs il ya un vol en direct
provenance de thaïlande
sur le ballon mais est tout cas toi
c'est réussi merci à vos franchement
bravo vous aussi c'est qu'avec secrets
beauté
vous
[Rires]
personne très très joli comme ça moi je
suis sûr d'être plus belle c'est non
je me maquille pas ne dites jamais c'est
petit c'est petit
c'est grand c'est grand c'est
steve jobs ne rajoute pas non plus oui
c'est vrai vous aimez bien tous les deux
ah oui si j'aime bien titre se
chamaillent mais il ya un truc derrière
tu vas bien bien chez
moi je pense que c'est votre style ouais
ouais tout à fait ah ouais
cela dit si tu nous regardes ses essais
lors du bal à
des blacks lors du bain aussi pour toi
aussi je pense en même temps forts
alors moi je me maquille pas beaucoup
cyril ouais comme ça j'essaie de garder
une peau nette propre à tous les jours
et quand je me maquille aux manches
paraît très très joli c'est vrai c'était
vraiment sinon je ressens moi je suis
cadavérique sinon c'est vrai sur la très
jolie ça donne envie et alors sinon je
fais on a la même clinique avec benjamin
ayatollahs le lien qui s'est créé et du
coup je fais de la mésothérapie ça c'est
bien sûr ça c'est du coup c'est les
petits cure de vitamines et ça me
redonne vraiment belle mais tu fais pas
ça toi non pas encore a tu donnerais
pas mais tu parce que c'est peut-être en
plus mais c'est vrai qu'on est
évidemment non mais toi tu as une
pochette on revoit encore sans déconner
ta peau vous parle non mais on dirait
que vous dites je dois bien ça pour
m'appelle et me dit de moi de losail
[Rires]
allez le top-3 beauté maintenant
les montagnes et à dieu
c'est pas forcément
le secret beauté vous quel est votre
secret détrompez vous la télé m'a changé
moi ah ouais moi je me douche en dix
minutes un quart d'heure grand max avant
de faire de la télé dix minutes un
carillon déjà non non je regarde quoi
dix minutes avec le temps qui s'est
écoulé à tos tri nations le temps que tu
sortes de tony et genre dix minutes
après tes habits y était préparé
ça
beaucoup
qu'il a toujours
aidé les deux pays je fais de la télé je
suis passé à des crèmes effet soleil
ouais je connaissais pas la
musique voilà ça peut remettre un pass 1
jour
je suis passé à de l'anti cernes ans
mais c'est une révolution pour moi trois
ans aiderait bien sûr je mets de l'anti
cernes avec mes potes se moque de moi je
suis là à mettre de lentilles servait
jeu j'ai un truc pour le comme les
filles pour les sert mathieu tu tournes
le truc et ça tient mon temps mais
roellinger ça je fais ça j'attends de
crem je m'épile sous les bras je peux
pour me souhaiter
mais tu nous as la part d'hommes mariés
[Applaudissements]
maintenant sur la zone
basso lui parler s'il te plaît est ce
que tu fais le regardant leur est posée
si on va te poser trois questions j'y
réponds juste par oui ou par non cotées
ban a dit quand tu vas dans un kiosque à
journaux oui est-ce que tu tournes à
tête devant lehmann une masculin têtu
le gaydar
choisi reçu au céda l'aida à jeune homme
curieux de moi je oui je
sais ma première qui tout doucement
est-ce que lorsque tu fais du sport tu
prends du plaisir à regarder des petits
camarades
[Rires]
on parlait performance
mois alors je pense qu'on a vraiment
besoin d'attendre
elle va confirmer sur le petit court
alors s'agirait du teil quant à la
guitare qui te démange
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non ces gars là qui dépensent voilà
alors là par contre seul arbre malade
arqués sur les marchés mondiaux c'est
bien c'est pas l'analyse du spécialiste
écologie musique et médecine et de cette
émission et je suis au regret famille
nous regardent de t'annoncer qu'il nous
reste pour trois mois d'hétérosexuels
prononcer sur plus c'est foutu au revoir
en été c'est vous du sivu cuba vraiment
s'assurer que
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
battu faut s'occuper de lui et là bas je
suis je suis de cyril de paris je suis
pas que ça a été mieux mais dans la
grande salle du métier tu sais pas moi
y'a pas je te le dire trois ans de télé
ça a été vite quand même à résoudre tant
chérie tu as tu sais pas quoi ça peut
toujours ordonner mois cyril mais j'ai
une interrogation parce que tout ce que
fait vraiment vous le faites vous aussi
non ça n'a rien à voir c'est à dire
je n'ai pas je suis désolé ce n'est pas
drôle à la
masia la coiffe et un sauna
faso n'a pas offert déjà mais c'est vrai
il va faire un sauna facial tout
emballage c'est juste pour me détendre
pour détourner aux antilles
pour détendre les khallouf
je vole y aller alors quel est votre
secret total alors jean maintien tu veux
un stylo pour noter
j'aime pas grand chose mais ma peau est
pas trop rester diriger la part la chose
de magnifique avait été exceptionnel
alors attention parce que je vais vous
donner vraiment c'est ces vieux et c'est
pas cher c'est pas mon ex est un produit
c'est l'eau de rose l'ordre ont tous les
jours depuis mai des années des années
sans rature elle s'est pas vraiment pas
cher et ça dans une
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
son pont champlain
comme caen qui pète
yao droz et aux roses il faut vraiment
les dames c'est vraiment pas cher et ça
c'est vrai si vrai nom mais bravo et bon
on va faire ça alors là sa ruche et
c'est ray lane paris pour s'assurer que
ça ça va tourner votre secret botha
alors c'est celui que je partage avec
sophie marceau que d'une amie mais elle
construit pas des masses mais alors là
bas vous connaissez le mime banane
pour toi t'as pas trop numéro tu vas pas
la plaine
dieu tu veux qu'on vérifie way du brésil
a connu une
grande assistance au
final
[Applaudissements]
je vais les bassaris tout c'est un peu
dur est pour marion
nécessite autant coucou bon ben
j'imagine oui
ce n'est pas par sophie la girafe
[Rires]
fait quoi là dis moi comment
utiliser un jeu
[Musique]
36 numéros de sa copine c'est
appris ça il n'a pas trouvé ça mais
messi mais non mais ça m'interpelle
richard et oui parce que vous la vapeur
but richard
non
richard gotainer
maladie parlé parlé parlé allait donc
benjamin tu fais partie de ces mecs qui
change de crayon dans je fais tellement
c'est beau mais elle aussi a changé de
prénom
j'explique je le fais aussi c'est des
gens connus les gens connus je mets pas
alors ah bon je connais personne j'avais
déjà connu et aimé par exemple je mets
pas serré l'alena si je prends un
téléphone allumé et le mec qui tombe sur
mon frère là son numéro 8 lui c'est
après cyril hanouna
je m'appelais comment 1
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais tony verront pas que des connards
qu'est ce qui se passait a marqué
connard mais qui est pavaner à nadal
tous âges et - 8 11 ans brouille les
pistes
oui marc
savard il a mis chr de
vaccin vaccin
[Applaudissements]
le sèche
sur la tête de ma mère on dira à nos
paroles
chr2 arrive en bretagne
d'accord mais sans déconner quand tu
m'as bien chr d'homme c'est bien sa
barque
r2 cyril hanouna et si j'avais fait ch
les gens auraient dit ah bah ça sonne la
paire de chr comme dans la restauration
le chr j'ai mis deux pour brouiller les
pistes
excuse moi c'est pas pour ça qu'on a
oublié son fils
moi je suis pas comme lui
on n'a pas besoin d'eux tu me lis tu que
tu me lis tout seul la saison bat son
plein de morceaux lui réponds oui je le
dis et je le fais vraiment qu'est ce que
vous faites je coupe une couille de
mathieu de la gauche
je la mets à la place de ce projecteur
[Rires]
beaucoup plus que la lumière
le foot donc donc ma sophie mon bébé je
donne tout à l'heure c'est pas con
succès elle nous regarde c'est assez
simple donc déjà le sort moi j'ai une
crème très simple qui fait que la
dépigmentation de la peau ça pique un
peu comme les acides de fruits donc ça
reja vers le s'applique souvent alors
ensuite sa voiture que je suis sûr c'est
comme un micro ping aussi tu veux bah
alors ça je sais pas les deux chez eux
alors je vais te tuer le match et codage
non je ne sais pas c'est là que le ghana
ce à
quoi la guitare qui me démangent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et on ne sont pas là j'ai pas la guitare
kino admettant envers les chiens
présentés envie de souffler donc j pop
et a pu faire un truc un petit peu
compliqué pas compliqué à faire mais il
faut la voir j'achète tous les dimanches
à cette demande et les aubergines bio et
ben
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moussa
le louvre le louvre ont été entièrement
je joue je reprends les petits les
petits pépins et les raisins qu'un petit
pépin d'aubergines d'accord que j'étale
sur le visage ouais alors quand j'ai un
copain et où je le fais pas c'est pas
toujours glam mais je les tables comme
ça et je dors toujours ne jamais dormir
sur un côté ou de l'autre pourquoi
gravité ça fait tomber impose à la pause
ça crée des rides et donc je dors
ces chants tout qu'une maigre un peu
leur doré comme ça avec l'aubergine sur
la gueule
te tire un peu la peau s'assèche
s'attire la peau d'un bateau qui les
filets celui qui s'exprime marceau est
vraiment pas pardon mais ça marche très
très bien donc si on arrive chez vous en
pleine nuit on vous retourne comme ça
avec de l'aubergine sur la gueule
[Applaudissements]